Isabella, how can I know the demographics
of my target audience?
Here's what you need to do.
Go to your Facebook page,
go to the analytics
and inside Facebook will give you a detailed
analytics about your audience demographics,
including a location,
trender and interests.
Another thing that you can do is the
competitor analysis.
This works well if you have a startup Facebook page.
Go to the competitor's Facebook page,
look at the people who likes,
who share, cares,
who comments on their posts
and then check their public data.
Another thing you can use
3rd party tools like brand watch, food, tweet,
Super Matrix.
I hope you Learned something today
and don't forget to follow for more.